once you start climbing then the biggest
hazard is avoiding all those big icicles
they're huge like the size of a family
car those beggars are really not
attached that was the rock and sometimes
we take that with small kick and they
laugh and fall down
my name is Clement Romano I'm an ice
climber and adventurer my climbing has
taken me to so many different places all
over the world
then how come Falls came into the radar
and it just changed everything I mean
it's the steepest ice you can find
anywhere once you're there and you're
walking toward the iPhone you just get
this feeling how big it is I mean it's
huge and it's deep have overhanging eyes
it's really rare usually iPhones are
formed vertically we didn't see
overhanging eyes before hunting Falls
I do believe life starts when you step
out of the comfort zone
climbing forces you to go outside of
your comfort zone it forces you to look
out for this fragile line between having
good time and not risking too much
faris present go on but once I'm there
and once I start to work on the route
the fur just goes away there's no more
fear just about logic and having good
time
right after school I just liked writing
like glimpse of a gym so I can climb
it's a dangerous sport but only think
that I'm afraid of is not being able to
get to those office
[Music]
exclaiming I don't think that it really
matters it's how big you are if you're
smaller you can hold on longer and your
hands might be smaller so we can fit
more fingers on hold I started climbing
in central Pike when I was six years old
now I don't think I can like live
without it when they're close to the top
of the sign we're trying to do confirm
Susan we feel like they're going to
explode and they're going to like first
open and you feel like you have to let
go but with timing you just can't let go
I think that climbing is it's obviously
a sport it's also like a dance you sort
of have to be able to like slow up the
wall and come up with your own technique
to get to accomplish I think people
shocked if I do something that they
can't do something because I'm still
really young and McGill so like doing
something that even if a guy can't do is
pretty special
[Music]
when I first started climbing I was so
bad I was so terrible so slow and
termites get up all the time I was like
how the heck are we going to go and do
Mount Kilimanjaro three words I don't
know those three words three of the most
important words in my life all
discoveries happen from I don't know
my name is Kyle Maynard and I have an
extremely hard time saying what it is
exactly that I do
I've been an athlete my entire life
football - wrestling - weightlifting and
resigning jiu-jitsu and now most
recently taking on climbing some of the
highest mountains in the world I was
born with congenital amputation -
basically means my arms and that the
elbows my legs and at the knees you know
I think some people they look at me and
maybe even feel sorry for me but really
truthfully my life isn't a whole lot
different than yours
you know I type on my computer the same
way you know use my phone just like
anybody else I'm on bumble like anybody
any other single person my age I'm going
to manage my first experience with
climbing really anything as significance
was in a cross the competition in 2010
the first workout was get to do a
thousand meter rowing machine in a
sprint up Stone Mountain everybody else
did it maybe 25 minutes it took me an
hour and 46 minutes at oralists get up
on my arms but I got to the top and I
was like wow this is breathtakingly
beautiful and I told my friend that
night I said I want to climb Mount
Kilimanjaro I don't know if I can I
don't know if I can't but I do know that
I want to try to figure it out I want to
go and find a way and get up there
there were ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear I literally started
with bath towels duct-taped on my arms
to my feet I couldn't go to the store
and buy a typical pair of shoes so we
had to come up with a unique solution
now to climb I use a carbon fiber
special custom shoe
I use those to bear crawl up Kilimanjaro
then me and my team we took on climbing
Mount Aconcagua the highest peak in
South America I felt my body was like in
full shutdown mode and it was brutal at
moments but it was breathtakingly
beautiful
at the top of that mountain you know you
can almost kind of make out and see like
the curvature of the earth I mean it was
just a moment I'll never forget the
reasons I climb aren't that different
from other people 95% of it does suck
I'm staring as a dirt I'm not even able
to go and talk to my friends and see the
beautiful views unless I stop and sit
down and look but that 5% that doesn't
suck it's amazing you're doing in a
place that there's no way my wheelchair
could have brought me there that's what
I love I'm not trying to live to be a
thousand like I wanted I want to go out
there and have my life mean something
when it gotten down and I've looked at
the mountain and I see what we've
achieved it's like wow maybe that was a
really bad idea that we were there but
it was beautiful
what's the highest you've ever expect at
almost a while
when you don't have a fear of heights
it's not really scary it's like being in
a craziest treehouse that you can
possibly imagine
that's Marc's in it he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent
they're called Torah Ledger's that's
hanging off the side of the mountain
you've been climbing for over 30 years
and his favorite walls to climb are
really really high alpine babe wall
climbing is the pursuit of scaling the
biggest cliffs on planet earth all in
here they take a few days to summit so
he has to camp out along the way so I
want to know what does it feel like to
sleep in a portaledge hanging off the
side of a mountain the one thing that's
more or less ever-present in the
mountains is when it can be pretty
violent you can experience
hurricane-force winds there's also this
thing that we call the Bronco ride wind
comes in hits a cliff and it really has
nowhere to go except for up eventually
it hits you and you're ledge and it can
lift the whole thing up so you can be
suspended and then of course the ledge
that slams into the wall you're just
thinking about surviving and that wasn't
the worst of it the smell in the ledges
if not it's not nice you don't change
your clothes you don't bathe it's like
it's gummy but people love it they
continue to climb and explore do all of
this punishment because there's still
that one question left how does it feel
the way it makes you feel is like a tiny
speck of dust very empowering it really
is just like kind of the most
spectacular spot that you could be done
planet Earth
Oh
[Music]